today is the voter registration deadline
from Missouri Friday October 12th
registration deadline for Oklahoma New
York and North Carolina Saturday October
13 Delaware Monday October 15th Virginia
Tuesday October 16th Kansas Maryland New
Jersey Oregon and West Virginia
Wednesday October 17 South Carolina
Massachusetts Friday October 19th
Nebraska Monday October 22nd Alabama
California and South Dakota Monday
October 29th Colorado and Washington
those are your voter registration
deadlines no I thought everything was
fine and then literally two months ago I
saw a tizzy of people online telling
everyone to check their voter
registration status I just previously
voted I thought my California status was
okay I went online I checked it I wasn't
registered to vote so I had to re
register myself now I've been literally
almost every other day checking in to
make sure I'm still registered to vote
please go check your registration status
it is weird to me how so many of you are
so apathetic about voting because you
think your voice doesn't count and then
you leave just very aggressive YouTube
comments thinking that your voice is the
only thing that matters oh why don't we
merge those two meet somewhere in the
middle where your voice actually counts
and has an effect on the community and
society that you existed by registering
to vote so let's talk about American
Music Awards fashions we're doing it
let's lighten everything up Jennifer
Lopez looks like she took down the
curtains in the Barbie boudoir and then
crapped I don't know a seat belt around
her so she just doesn't age so it
doesn't matter as long as her breasts
are kind of out she can wear anything
she wants and she looks fantastic also
she just knows how to pose like kind of
a guppy fish that got freshly just
mouth-breathing and judged cute Carrie
Underwood she's pregnant right cuz
there's no other reason to pose like
this it's yours not the dress is really
cute shows off your shoulders and also
shows where some of the sperm went down
here and then some of them went rogue oh
oh no you must be law when you do a red
carpet and you're pregnant you have to
do this because you do this why are you
acknowledging your baby people love to
get mad about stuff goose is already mad
at me for making that okay we're fine
I know you love Carrie Underwood I think
she was right for slashing the tires
it's okay offset and cardi B whoa she's
basically doing like a Moulin Rouge
version of the Kim Kardashian's sofa Met
Gala
extravaganza this is very Michael's
artificial flower section meets offset
cute kamila Kibeho
oh this is very understated she's got a
corset going it she's got a classic toss
old freshly Pantene pro-v commercial
hair going it feels like there's gonna
be a different bottom happening but then
something might have happened last
minute and then you were like to your
assistant give me your pants and you put
them on and this is what happens you
know what I don't hate it that cinched
race though good god is anyone checking
if she's breathing Heidi Klum oh thanks
thank god she's there you guys know me
god I only feel secure when I see that
Heidi Klum shows up at award ceremonies
and when you guys show up
and register to vote for your respective
state deadline for midterm elections
November 6 yeah ty dolla sign and lauren
auguri you know what pronounce both of
them wrong two negatives equals a
positive why do they both look so sad
Laurens dress looks like a Windows
desktop or she looks like a very female
Hot Wheels branded thing and then ty
dolla sign just looks like he came from
a really unfortunate catering gig and
untucked his shirt and just why they
look so sad it looks so sleepy can we
get them some cots cute Busy Philipps
I love Busy Philipps I followed her on
Instagram I think she's absolutely
fantastic I love this look on there the
mom but she looks hot I know she's got a
new show I'm super excited for it he is
a very very cool human being to me she
named her daughter Cricut and like what
else could you want from busy sequin
bell-bottom pants and a blazer and a bra
I don't know what kind of crystal she's
running around her neck oh and then
she's got like a ha fourth-grade
Catholic school student here ah busy how
dare you I love her I think she's great
I'm very excited for her and her she'll
register to vote god dammit Rio hora
whoa Rita Ora in my experience of seeing
her on red carpet is very like sexually
provocative and this is that but it's a
lot of like oops
in different areas like when you buy a
balloon from Party City and they're like
we'll inflate it for you like that no
I'll do it at home and you have a helium
tank then it only does like the like the
middle part of the elephant not the
other legs and extraneous pieces we can
all relate to Matthew constants whoo I
love this dress so much I love this look
so much love a high-neck long-sleeve
short dress situation especially with
fran drescher hair Constance you wooed
me GZ and palsy you guys are difficult
and paws in who knows what's going on
you guys are back together
great I read just I had
read articles that read headlines oh
that sounds like my Real Housewives
technically you know what they say in
Hollywood keep your relationships like
your teeth completely hidden cute
come on anyone that walks onto a red
carpet and solo cup isn't Kim Zolciak
because let's be real she is the queen
of that so host you are post Zolciak on
the red carpet Red Solo Cup game however
I do appreciate a fool this I love a
good turquoise on turquoise meets Steve
Jobs turtle neck meets face and snakes I
think my stepmom has that Chico's
bedazzled belt and she probably wishes
that she had those boots and so I like I
appreciate all of this cute Taylor Swift
I love this so much and I know so many
of you are gonna think I'm just being
partisan to the fact that you know I
have loved Taylor Swift for so long but
like this is very good
it's simple and complex she looks
pixelated and textured my queen calm
slash edu slash Dakota Iowa boy calm
everything else bad bunny okay this is a
person that was the party B and dominant
on goes person but it's looks like not a
lot here's my question if you're gonna
draw a third eye on your forehead and
then also are sunglasses you gotta
accommodate the third eye you can't
protect these two eyes down here and
then let this one right it would be even
cooler if you just had like a little one
going up here or being like let's
protect this guy this looks like you let
Instagram decide your outfit also I'm
sorry for your feet it looks like you
have to have orthopedics I wish you the
best cuz word shows are a lot of
standing up and I hope that your
ligaments are okay cute Tyra Banks what
actually has a train conductor meets
Pirates of the Caribbean meets wench
meets Dancing with the Stars
meets like a Hadid sister Zhu du liebe
oh my god you look a little bit like a
client called bride were like you came
out in the dress and then your best
friend that you brought with you that's
like secretly super jealous that you're
getting
it is a then your mom is like oh she's
been divorced a couple times and then a
friend it's like but you love it and
it's great cute this is beauty exit I
thought this was Kelly Coco meets
Julianne Hough what is happening right
now
meg Ryan in a modern rom-com from the
chin up and then like a tea stepmom
[ __ ] that shows up at the prom as a
chaperone from the neck bottom Nick
bottom from the neck bottom said always
looks adorable always looks wildly
uncomfortable that's what I've always
said about him yeah Vanessa Hudgens oh
she came to take the prom queen crown
this is literally like I'm maid of honor
that's gonna be single at the wedding
and you know what god blessing you wish
her luck Tracee Ellis Ross she was the
host of the American Music Awards and
goddamn it she can literally wear
anything and the fact that she's a
female a tuxedo a DS glam rock I don't
even know what this is and I like it so
much it's confusing to me in the most
exciting way possible oh okay I know
that I might have missed a lot of people
that you might have wanted me to comment
on and I'm very sorry for that
as always regardless I hope you enjoyed
this video leave a comment down below on
if you are registered to vote or not
that's literally all I want to know
please these please I don't know
also if you wanna watch a documentary
that honestly gave me so much backstory
that had no idea about that chronicles
Russians previous collusion with other
countries elections and really
chronicles the decades in which Trump
has been in bed with Russians watch
active measures on Hulu not sponsored
don't need to be sponsored this is the
most amazing insane will make you mad
documentary of all time active measures
and also she says critics in a polite
way